NOW BACK TO "ONE NATION" WITH
BRIAN KILMEADE.
BRIAN: A STUNNING ADMISSION HAVE
TIKTOK.
WORKERS IN CHINA CAN SPY ON
EUROPEAN USERS.
IT COMES WITH CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
ACCESSING DATA STORED ON THE APP
WORLDWIDE.
THE COMMISSIONER IS ASKING FOR
TIKTOK TO BE BANNED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
JOINING US, MIKE POMPEO.
DO YOU BELIEVE WE SHOULD GET RID
OF TIKTOK, MR. SECRETARY.
>> 100%.
AND IF THE GOVERNMENT WON'T DO
IT, THE PARENTS SHOULD.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
3 1/2 YEARS AGO.
IT'S A POWERFUL TOOL WITH DEEPLY
EMBEDDED AI.
THINK ABOUT YOUR KIDS, FACING
RECOGNITION FEATURES, WHO THEY
ARE TALKING TO.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD IT
RIGHT, BUT WE DIDN'T GET IT
DONE.
WE NEED TO PREVENT THIS TOOL AND
OTHERS LIKE IT FROM IMPACTING
AMERICAN SECURITY.
BRIAN: I SEE PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA SITTING ON THE FLOOR
TALKING TO A TIKTOK STAR.
IS HE NAIVE?
>> NAIVE AND RECKLESS PROMOTING
A TOOL USED BY PEOPLE MOST
VULNERABLE.
THEY BROUGHT TIKTOK INFLUENCERS
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY PUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AT
RISK BY DOING THAT.
BRIAN: IT SEEMS AMERICA'S
ENEMIES ARE STANDING UP AGAINST
US AND DARING US TO DO
SOMETHING.
OF COURSE, TALKING ABOUT THE
ROCKETS AND MISSILES BEING SOLD
TO RUSSIA AND IRAN, SELLING CAMG
KAMIKAZEE DRONES TO RUSSIA.
YOU KNOW IT.
THE WORLD SEES IT.
THEY ARE BEGINNING TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WILL DO.
THEY WILL HEDGE.
IF AMERICA ISN'T GOING TO BE
STRONG, CAPABLE AND BOLD WE'LL
MAKE FRIENDS WITH THE RUSSIANS
AND ESTABLISH AN EMBASSY IN
TEHRAN.
WE NEVER HAD TWO DOZEN MISSILES
FIRED LESS THAN TWO DOZEN HOURS
FROM THE NORTH KOREANS.
THIS IS A SIGN AMERICA HAS LOST
ITS PLACE ON THE GLOBAL STAGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHOSE CREDIBILITY AND RESPECT
FOR AMERICA HAS WANDERED OFF.
AND IT CONTINUED WITH THE LOSS
OF 13 AMERICAN LIVES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
BRIAN: IF WE SPOT THE ROCKETS
GOING OVER, WHY DON'T WE STOP
IT.
>> WE DID DURING THE YEARS I WAS
CIA DIRECTOR AND SECRETARY OF
STATE.
WE KNOW PRECISELY HOW TO DO
THIS, WE KNOW PRECISELY HOW TO
FIND THEM.
IT'S IMPERFECT, BUT IT'S SCIENCE
AND WE CAN PUTS RESOURCES ON IT.
THEY ARE FEARFUL THEY WILL
PROVOKE AN ADVERSARY.